to your points the reason it's people is
if you have continuity you win I talk in
like sign language and like ESP with
like Marcus and Hannah and you and like
and Kailyn and like we go fast speed
matters when you trust your fellow
employee you're actually working on the
work instead of the politics so many of
you have friends right now that you guys
over a beer when you hang out like
they're just talking all the energies on
the toxic [ __ ] politics I know why
we're gonna win and it's because of how
I think about this
I just want to start with yesterday was
the first day of work I missed because
of sickness in 13 years so I'm glad that
didn't happen today because that would
have been a bummer
um I want to start with how excited I am
to be with all of you
um this is obviously the largest
residency class we've had this is a
program that really works for the
organization and for the people that go
through it
um even people that don't end up at
Vayner have been able to leverage it
quite a bit which obviously makes me
incredibly proud
um I've been hearing incredible things
about this residence class from so many
different places and angles and
different people and so who knows to you
collectively
um and honestly I want this time
together to be the most valuable it
possibly can and so I uh I definitely am
looking to do as much q a as possible to
your points but maybe maybe you have an
opening question or two or three based
on what you know the tone and Tedder is
of the group and then after that let's
just go into hand raising and rock and
roll
I told Gary you're putting me on the
spot I never prep questions for you
I'm thrilled to go directly to q a I
didn't know if there's anything that you
cut anything you sense or is in the air
or that you've heard from the screw or
anything on your mind yeah we just had
our first fireside chat uh last week
with t and uh we're pairing Folks up now
which is a whole kind of new uh energy
so really I'd really love to turn over
to the group to maximize time quite
frankly so
great so use the hand raise
I will tell you who goes and we will
rock and roll all right Austin first up
thank you hey Gary
um so simply put you're seeing a lot of
platforms kind of try to do
cross-functionality like you're seeing
Tick Tock Implement a be real sort of
functionality in the photo functionality
and you're seeing Instagram now compete
with be real and do more video Centric
stuff do you think it's gonna end up
being everyone doing everything or do
you think it's going to resettle to
everyone kind of just sitting in their
comfort zone what they are best at well
meta's been doing this long before you
know with Facebook and Instagram and now
you have Tick Tock doing it
because they're such a big player I
think everybody will try everything if
there's a standalone app that they think
is a feature but some will stick and
some won't for example let's go back to
way back when this really started
Snapchat stories
right Snapchat comes out stories works
then you have Instagram that was like
that big moment a lot of you probably
remember this Instagram ads it it's
stuck
but so did Twitter and Facebook and
other things and some platforms it
didn't stick what about Clubhouse when
Clubhouse got hot I made a video that
said everyone's gonna try to make this a
feature everybody did Facebook concluded
Instagram all of them it was Twitter
spaces that stuck
right so I think with be real or
anything we see for the next half decade
all the leaders will try to implement it
and
some will have it stick because it
worked for them and they did a good job
and some won't and that will be the
constant flow that we see
all right thank you so much of course
brother
hi Gary
um so I just started on my first new
business pitch which is really exciting
and I was wondering what your biggest
piece of advice was for entering this
kind of new fast-paced assignment
mindset or like tactical things whatever
the concept of if I'm playing a new
business what should I be thinking about
is that is that where you're going I
just want to make sure yeah
you know I think I think the thing to
look out for is what are clients
reacting well to
that's always a good thing to learn you
know like why did that client
think that that was cool or why did they
ask us to double click into that
um
I think that this you know a lot of what
we're trying to do in general and
definitely a new business is osmosis
you know I think the other thing to
think about is what to parrot
you know from the kalens and others so I
think it's a huge learning experience
but by far the most interesting thing
I'd be looking for is what are people
reacting best to and why
cool thank you of course
hey Gary how are you it's nice to
finally meet you I hope you're having a
great day
um my question is uh what advice would
you give to someone who's eager to try
out many different roles and how should
one go about finding their place at
Vayner
you know um
I think Boehner is a very unique
organization where
um
where we're willing to let people
transfer from media to account account
to strategy
strategy to project management so
you know figuring out what you're about
is raising your hand and asking to try
something new
and you're at the right company for that
and whether that works out here or
somewhere else it's a constant game of
raising your hand and patiently and
humbly asking to try something else
because you don't really know
what you love or you're great at until
you try it like there's a lot of people
who love riding bikes who are actually
meant to be better skateboarders but
they never tried skateboarding which is
just too bad and so you know I think
staying curious asking questions of the
people that are in those departments
Boehner's best strength
is that we have a culture where people
will feel weird if they don't like reply
to questions or like are are not nice to
each other so take advantage of that
while you're here you Slack
right use use it and ask people
you know hey I'm in media but I I'm
curious about project management why do
you like it what do you have to be good
at
so staying curious and staying on the
offense and knowing that you're in a
company that rewards it
yeah thank you because uh sometimes I
feel like I want to do like too many
different things and I feel like it's
like too much going on so thank you
stay with me here for a second the thing
is it's good to try to do a lot of
things or be curious but curiosity is
the strength
curiosity is a strength you know the
only thing you have to do is be
empathetic to the organizations you work
in
so like if you're a Vayner what are you
what are you a resident for right now
uh I'm a Creator resident but I've been
like shadowing like PMs and like trying
to look maybe for at PCS and like
Community Management just like all
around as long as you're fair in return
to Vayner
if they want you to be a creator for a
year before you even try those other
things
I think we're curious youngsters get
caught is audacity
you know there's that level of
entitlement and it's not a gen Z thing I
hate when everyone's like gen Z I saw
this in [ __ ] Generation X when I was
22.
like people are people are entitled
consistently
you know and so you know as long as
you're empathetic that Vayner would like
to give you that at-bat and project
management but it's not ready just yet
and whether that's Vayner or you decide
to go somewhere else for all of you as
long as you're empathetic to the
organization if they're really trying
well then and you're willing to be
patient then you're in a good spot it's
the LA I will say that where younger
Generations got caught is the world's
faster now
because of technology and so patience is
definitely something people struggle
with
you know and because of the way the
world is insecurity has always been
poisoned
but now people literally are living
their lives so publicly that if they're
insecure
and they want success so that they can
Flex
it eliminates patience
I mean the amount I mean you you'd be
stunned if you saw some of the emails I
get from employees who left here for a
five thousand dollar raise when we
weren't willing to do it because they
just wanted to buy some dumb [ __ ]
and now we're like what the [ __ ] did I
do you know
and so
you guys are all and gals are so young
it's about being thoughtful but do not
downplay
you don't have you're not chaotic you're
not
too CR you know crazy about that that's
good you're trying to figure out your
[ __ ]
I think it's a strength but you just
have to be you know unless you're an
entrepreneur and you control your way
you have to know that there's you know
we're the most pro-employee org on Earth
and even for us it's hard for you to be
like hey I want to be PCS because that
spot might not exist at this exact
second
thank you of course the first time well
thank you the first time we met you
mentioned that we are the future of the
company and I'm in that within this
Residency program I've been having that
as a mindset going into the next five
years what is the best mindset that and
the learning path that I can take to
become the future of this company
and I'm not saying to come where you are
I'm just saying like to grow in this
company and to be to be a big part of it
uh it's a great question I think a
couple things one is self-awareness
you know
let me give you an example of what I
mean by that there are plenty of times
and I'm as happy as it gets
professionally and there are still
plenty of times that I say huh I wonder
how cool it would have been to have the
DNA that would have made me pop like I'm
envious of a lot of my senior employees
I'm like you know
you know like yesterday like being sick
that was it was not only bad to have 103
fever it was even worse knowing that I
was missing things that were really
important and like I can't like rely on
anybody else to do that role
so I think first of all self-awareness
when you have ambition
you know even you asking that question
my fear is that you push yourself into
places on an ideology versus the reality
of who you actually are
so I think the best way people can be
the future of this company is
one they have a good sense of themselves
two they have a good sense of what they
want in life financially creatively
work-life balance three this is a big
one I want everybody to pay attention to
this one three
that they have the capacity to change
their mind five years from now so some
of you right now might be like I
actually do want Gary's job I want to be
the C Global CEO of vaynerx in 20 years
and I think that's [ __ ] rad
on the flip side you may fall deeply
deeply in love in seven years
and then start a family and be like [ __ ]
that you know I want to be like my mom
or dad or I want to be the reverse of my
mom and dad and I want to be at every
recital and every ball game and that's
not going to let you be the global CEO
of vaynerx that's just real talk
so I think that if you have a good sense
of who you are if you're comfortable
in who you are and if you're willing to
change your mind of what you want that's
a huge starting point the next Things
Are One
let there be no confusion unless you are
a very nice person and nice to others
you can only grow so much here
there's nobody that gets to the upper
levels so if you're in a place where
you're still insecure you you know like
if you have big Ambitions here and you
know you're testy because you yourself
are slightly unhappy I started thinking
about things like meditation
I started thinking about things like
therapy because there's been so many
people that have the talents to get to
the highest levels here but lost along
the way because they didn't have the
human capacity to be the person I need
them to be with each other they're
political they worry about their money
they they try to tear down other people
who they think are trying to take their
spot
so all that stuff and then finally
and I'm gonna pound the living [ __ ] out
of this
without the essence stopped you can only
get so far
strategic organic content and something
you'll be hearing a lot about soon
called pack platforms and culture
the future of communication over the
next 10 years which is going to impact
all of you is whoever is the most
significantly talented in understanding
how the platforms work and understand
the cultural nuances of hundreds of
different consumer segmentations not
culture as in the cool slang term for
urban hip-hop culture I mean do you know
what 40 to 47 year old Middle America
Hunter and fisherman type dudes care
about and how to get them to buy
chocolate milk
right so it's all cultures it's all ages
genders races interests Financial levels
and one thing I worry about in this
company I talk to the team you know as
most of you saw the video with Brittany
King and we just have a very strong
strong passion around the eni and
different things that nature one of the
things I see from so many of my
well-intended
senior Executives is they think the
strategists and creatives that will be
best for the consumer cohorts are the
people that look like the consumer
cohorts and that's not true
right like I don't think like you know
you know a 40 year old woman is the only
person that knows how to sell 40 year
old woman stuff I don't think you have
Hispanic to understand how to sell stuff
to Hispanics and so I see a lot of
well-intended subconscious thinking that
I'm excited to change over time because
I
fit only one demo you know with my age
and gender but my whole career is built
on my empathy and compassion and
intuition around all people and so I
it's also I think a lot of you are
probably aware that in your Circles of
friends family acquaintances my my brand
hits for a lot of people all that looks
super different
and it's because you know the messaging
is contextual even though it's still
grounded in the same truth of love over
hate
I really appreciate that thank you and
yeah that's why I hopped on to actually
divas that there are a couple of tick
tocks in there for them because it's
something that I've found funny but I
appreciate that Gary thank you keep
going
I appreciate you Sarah
how you doing G I'm good my man oh man
so good to see you um I don't know if
you remember uh NF tampons that's me but
thank you so much for being here thanks
for having us
um my question to you
is I mean I'm on Consulting I'm in I'm a
Creator I'm in Consulting um so I'm I've
been introduced to pack in some capacity
yeah um and my question is how do we get
um
how do we push clients more towards uh
just diving themselves deeper into
culture and not being so
not to say like let's not focus on
what's trending but like be more ahead
of that curve of where culture is going
as a brand
I think for us
all of you don't have this context but
the strides we've made in the last 36
months are so profound for us it's
there's going to be no option if you
work with us
so it's gonna be easy it's gonna be a
byproduct of how we sell how we talk
because of what you are doing and look
you know you've had a real front row
seat like Consulting was a really good
spot this time around you know like it's
how life works so you're getting to see
a lot of the stuff
and you can see what's happening
you know with Jimmy John's this or St
Jude that like
we're writing about this you're either
relevant or you're not
you know and so
I think for us to answer a question
we're gonna get them to do it because
they're going to have no damn choice
you know like it's what they're paying
us to do so I think we're going to
continue to go more and more there
makes sense makes sense yeah
appreciate you I'm really glad
hey Gary how you doing
I'm well my man
um all right so what I want to touch
upon is obviously everyone talks about
the culture and now that we've been here
for a while I've experienced that
firsthand
um and it's kind of hard to describe
like how how effective it is and and you
know I understand why that makes us
different than other agencies but my
question about culture is how did you
get to this point with your mindset
regarding culture like where does that
come from is that something that you
were raised with is there a moment that
made you realize that
um
it's
it was
something I was born with
and I know that because
it was funny I had my
I had my friends that I grew up with
when I was
from first grade to seventh grade in
Edison New Jersey on the on a podcast
the other day
and it we didn't get to some of these
things on the podcast but it got my
brain remembering they were talking
about this is really funny actually they
were talking about the fact that I used
to get into fights a lot
so I was like a real like Scrapper New
Jersey kid like like I'm talking like
fix like bikes yeah and and it reminded
me that a lot of my fights came from me
defending when people picked on people
so I was on like some superhero [ __ ]
from the get kind of thing meaning I've
always been uncomfortable
with
people being mean to people
it's what really [ __ ] me up with
Society right now because both sides of
the political party are fully into that
place now
and so I
the answer to your question is
this is some real [ __ ] I am so
uncomfortable
when there is tension I can't even live
within it
it's it's a visceral reaction to me
you know
even if like you know this Dustin even
when me and Dustin are traveling
right if I don't like the way his face
looks I'm like are you good like it's my
natural state everything cool
like I don't like it and because I have
so much intuitive like spiritual energy
that comes natural to me I'm always I
always know
I mean there's some [ __ ] like some of
the stories of employee you know how
some of the eight and nine and ten year
employees come and tell you [ __ ] like he
knows or this it's because it's it's
some spooky [ __ ] I say it's like I'll be
going to the bathroom
and I'm like I don't like the way that
felt and then I'm like admins can you
give me 15 with that per like
so
there was no choice then so cool I gave
you that frame up now
it gets even weirder
then I go into working for my dad at 14
so this is my natural state
this is my essence
and then I go into work in my dad's
liquor store
and it's the toxic disaster
my dad who I struggled with for the
first seven or eight years on this and
maybe even 10 years on this and maybe
even 20 years on this until I realized
that my dad grew up in the Soviet Union
where every employee stole everything
and it was so toxic that it Formed him
my dad's point of view was that
employees were your enemy
my dad's greatest fear 24 7 365 in my
teenage years was
the employees are stealing
right and
I just want to say
um that like congratulate you on the
fact that you've established a culture
here that genuinely feels like a family
only two months in with my team and idea
generation and teamwork and everything
that goes into the ad business
um it's never felt so like pure and
genuine and it comes so easy so I think
you've done a great job at you know
responding to that I appreciate that and
I'll say this for the people on here and
if you don't have it if that's a 10 and
you're sitting right now and you're not
you're not in the chat and you're
thinking that's not what I have
then that's that's something I realize
is real we have 1800 employees
and I'm a human being I understand how
[ __ ] works I'll give you an example
there was something that happened years
ago that really stuck with me
somebody who was an 11 on culture an 11.
out of nowhere
like little smoke started popping up XYZ
made me upset today XYZ
and when I got to the bottom of it
her father was dying from brain cancer
and she brought that to work
and like of course when you're scared
you know this all of you know this about
yourself when you're most scared it's
only one of two things that are gonna
happen
and so I don't sit here in an ivory
Tower delusional that everybody's
hitting at an 11 of a ten
but I do sit here in my Ivory Tower
knowing that I spend an ungodly amount
of energy time and effort
you know and tons of money compared to
companies that look like this on trying
to get every situation to 11 of 10.
and that's why we went because there's
never an interest for us to look the
other way because we don't value the
money we value the culture
we need the money to pay the bills honey
Empire right I got to be practical this
is not delusional School
but I'm feeling really confident and I
will tell you every month that goes by
we've got it better and better and
better and that's really especially
lasts for years and that's really
exciting to me
thank you thank you just to build on
that Gary I think that was a nice
reminder for me in the All Hands the
other day when I think one of the
questions was how are we going to win
and I thought you were going to go right
to stock you're like people first like
oh [ __ ] that's right that's what we
started with so what's a good reminder
for me too personally as well yeah to
your points the reason it's people is if
you have continuity you win
I talk in like sign language and like
ESP with like Marcus and Hannah and you
and like and Kailyn and like we go fast
speed matters
you know like when you when you trust
your fellow employee you're actually
working on the work instead of the
politics
so many of you have friends right now
that you guys over a beer when you hang
out like they're just talking all the
energies on the toxic [ __ ] politics
right all of it so yeah I mean I I know
why we're gonna win and it's because of
how I think about this
um
hi um thank you Sarah and hi Gary oh
just a little tip Gary um in case you
are feeling not so great still Ginger
turmeric and some oreganol you'll it'll
clear you up for sure
um my grandma Esther who's no longer
with us and my girlfriend Mona both
agree with you very very feverishly yes
very much we come from a long line of
herbal women
um but basically my question is actually
kind of building on what we were just
speaking on
um we know that we're moving into the
recession and like unprecedented time so
just as a Creator I wanted to know like
what I could provide do or communicate
to my audience members you know but you
know that is valuable to them during all
these craziness and times because I have
a very very strong moral compass but
still being beneficial to the client as
well so like I I hate selling out you
know I come from the hood Harlem so I'm
just like I don't want to sell out but I
also like you said
we have bills to pay so it was a way to
be valuable to them
you know the it's a great question first
of all one of the things you know to be
honest
even though yesterday was even though
yesterday was tough like I can't believe
I got sick for the first time ever today
it gave me a few minutes to kind of like
especially once my fever broke to look
at the election and it was interesting
what went through my mind I'm like man
it wasn't even like a political stance
it was an opera my brain was in
operations of Vayner mode I was like wow
this very big day for the Democrats is
just going to make my day-to-day a lot
easier
because people's tensions are not going
to be as high because you know not to
talk too much politics but obviously we
have a young company and that lends
itself to a certain direction
you know
the the biggest thing is
a
four years ago I told a lot of our
employees we expect our clients
to be our activists for us
right right and so
similarly to that with your question you
can share your truth on what will be
relevant
but
you have to be empathetic that these
people have jobs
right and they may have to make it 20 to
30 percent more vanilla
than you would want it to be I actually
think it's one of the biggest reasons we
win I because I have no boss I'm able to
go a hundred absolutely
and so most of our clients on a good day
can only go 70 and we have to be
empathetic to that
understood for sure thank you Gary of
course
hey everyone hey Gary hey Sarah you guys
Sarah is a superhero like flowers to you
Sarah but uh my question Gary uh you've
been talking a lot about like how the
last 36 months have been like really
crucial
I just wanted to ask you what is
probably like
the most memorable or like the most
important life experience you've had
like in the last like recent years that
have made you like
really develop and grow as a person with
just like business-wise personally wise
in relation to anything Candor has
forever been a weakness of mine and has
always been the
um weakness of this organization
you know I just don't like confrontation
you know the you know your gift is your
is your curse
the reason we have this great
culture is because I hate negativity and
confrontation the reason it took us a
little while to get it really good is I
love it so much that I mistreated it and
where Candor really mattered I was
unable to deliver it thus that trickled
down to the organization
and so the biggest vulnerability this
company had for years was
the most senior people over time
realized that they didn't actually know
where they sat with me
and so what that did was it was a very
devastating day Mike no question the
most difficult day of my career happened
about four years ago when I realized so
my number one thing is that my job is to
eliminate fear
as a leader when I had to realize
looking myself in a mirror that me not
being cancerous led to a lot of people
not knowing where they stood which
actually created fear was heartbreaking
and you know I feel like now
we're much better for it and so I would
say that is the answer thank you sir hey
guy
um good how are you man very good I
guess my question is kind of related to
the future of the internet
um like you might have seen like people
are saying we're in a crypto winter
right now and we wanted to know like I
wanted to know like what's your
perspective on why you think there's a
divide between people who are pro
metaverse and why like big tech
companies like Snap and apple and stuff
are still like nieces or who don't
believe fully who don't give in to the
concept of the metaverse and what's
really causing this divide according to
you and
Financial interests
okay Microsoft wasn't into the internet
financial interest
and and timing uh you know the metaverse
if we're talking metaverse
you know because you know this the
metaverse can mean a lot of different
things
so if you're using the metaverse as
slang for web 3
that's one thing
AKA blockchains that have consumer
applications like nfts if you're using
the metaverse like VR
I believe that VR will happen one day
but I also think Facebook could over
invest in it because it might be too
early
you know like I don't like investing in
things all the way
um
until it's a little more obvious that
it's real
nobody here knows anybody who spends two
hours a day on VR
so I think that you know
but I think to answer your question it's
all financial interest and by the way
this is one day you'll realize what's
cool about being 45 or 46 or 47 like I'm
going to be in four days is it's pattern
recognition
let me give you an example you know how
people say like why does that need to be
an nft can't you do it this way
let me give you one that's going to blow
all your minds
when I launched my library.com in 1997.
which in itself is wild because there
are many people here who were born after
1997.
so when I launched winelibrary.com in
1997.
do you know what people said to me
they said Gary why do you need a website
you could just do a catalog
think about that
like for real like real business people
real grown-ups
like why would you build a website you
could just do a catalog
you know why do I think tickets are
going to be nfts
because they're better than QR codes
and why did all our tickets be our
become QR codes what was wrong with
paper
so
this is just pattern recognition for me
right thank you
hey Gary how's it going uh thank you for
taking the time to meet us my name is
I'm on the media side of PNG grooming uh
so my question for you is what would you
say to be the turning point in your life
that kind of shifted to who you are
today and what could we take like from
that like if there's any advice that you
can give to us from something that's
happened to you in your life that made
you to who you are today
I don't think there's something super
clear brother I think what the real
answer to this question is something
happened to me between 9 and 14 that
isn't very clear to me still that
flipped me to a level of self-awareness
and confidence that guided me my whole
life
but like one thing that is very Bonkers
to me is how completely
non-penetratable I was to peer pressure
in high school
I still don't fully even understand it
to be honest
like when I recall the things I didn't
do in the face of why it would seemingly
be so easy and so obvious that you
should do that if you're a kid
good parenting good DNA circumstances
I do think there are some big advantages
of growing up in the dirt
you know
um but
what I would tell you to give you an
answer that maybe brings value is how
quickly can you fall fully in love with
yourself
like that you're so in love with
yourself
that you don't need validation from
anybody else
while you balance that love with of
yourself with extraordinary levels of
humility to offset the vulnerability of
loving yourself
awesome thank you got it
Gary how you doing
I'm well brother how are you
good I'm gonna throw you probably the
most important question all off speed
here Jets great season so far yes at
what point at what point do you think
this becomes for you a disappointment
season where like you had these
expectations now
um what point do you think like it's
like damn like that sucked not gonna
happen I'm too locked in and this is how
it has happened in the past many times
this season
is such a blessing because it's a year
ahead of schedule
a lot of things have gone wrong from an
injury front
but
it's you know I'm too educated in
knowing what's happened here which is
we've hit too much Pay Dirt in the draft
and we've managed our salary cap too
well
of course you can always have injuries
look at Buffalo they got it looks like
they dodged a bullet but
you know earlier this week there were
scenarios where Josh Allen might be out
for the year and they did everything
right
five years before we did to get to this
point
the Jets could literally Win Every Game
the rest of the Year brother which they
won't but they could and could lose in
the first round of the playoffs and I'd
still be ecstatic
because the foundation of what they have
is to choose strong
so not this year
I think years like that where you get
disappointed when the team overperforms
is when you know you can't go back the
following year
you have six free agents that are your
best players
the Jets seven best players are in their
first two years of their life it's crazy
what the Jets have right now this is it
finally got there you know yeah no great
season thank you
hey how we doing everybody uh
uh just wanted to ask this is a
follow-up from a question that was like
a little bit earlier but you talked
about uh building self-awareness and
like doing that as a practice over time
but at this stage of Life sort of in
this kind of position where we all are
how would you recommend building that
kind of awareness like right now in
steps there's only two
this has always been a question I've
always been scared of and over the last
seven or eight years it's gotten the
hair easier there's two ways I think
about self-awareness one is incredibly
personal and the other one requires
others
one
I actually think that almost everyone
actually knows the truth about
themselves but have built up so much
posturing that it becomes their
subconscious and they can't even like
tell the difference
so I talk a lot about with my friends
and family and
people I care about and and groups like
this like just really go there in a dark
room by yourself you know and like just
really go there and be like no no like
Gary's right I'm just gonna do this
because I think this is gonna make me
happier and just like actually put pen
to paper on the [ __ ] that you're full of
[ __ ] about
and I really like even just watching you
all like move right now on screen
all of you can probably come up with one
thing that you say and act on that you
know is not true
so that's Big John right that's big the
second one is kind of cool which is like
how do you get three to four people that
know you the best
right
and you spend some time with them
prepping you prepping them like you have
a dinner you hanging out once and you
basically build them towards this day a
couple weeks out
where you ask them to really call it
like it is from their perspective what
are you good at what are you bad at
what do you do that [ __ ] them up but
they've never been able to tell you
because you love them they love you
and you kind of make these three to ten
people feel really safe to really tell
you
and you know that it's true
the thing that works for me is I don't
lie to myself
I don't want to trick myself
you know what I mean John like people
posture bro
like I just and this goes back to loving
yourself over others I think the biggest
reason people posture is because they
value other people's opinions too much
you know the facts you know what I mean
my man like I'm just not really worried
about if someone thinks I'm cool or good
looking or smart or clever like I'm just
not there like of course I'd like to be
liked but it's like and I'm normally
very liked by anybody that knows me you
know I know that you guys and gals have
people in your life that don't like me
that's because they watched one video
Once out of context and take a hot take
they don't really know me like that
and so
like right like like it's just it's just
really being honest with yourself and
and putting the people that are closest
to you into a framework of being honest
with you and then you start working on
it let me let me give you an Insight at
this young of an age that might really
hit for some of you
let me tell you why there's no value in
posturing or faking the funk
it's because you can trick the 98
percent
and the two percent is who you actually
want
and the two percent are the ones that
are turned off by your [ __ ]
you're just tricking people that are
trickable
that
yeah that's pretty much fixed
Gary my grand my grandfather he taught
me you can't [ __ ] a [ __ ] that was his
line so you know totally that you know
what couldn't have said it better to you
like because nobody has ever tricked me
ever ever in my entire life nobody has
tricked me ever
I know that there are other what am I
one of one definitely not and so I say
to myself then why would I do that and
lose
Equity with the people that are most
talented
just to trick the ones that are
trickable because when you're tricking
trickable people somebody else might
trick them onto you
that's what I was about to ask like in
terms of like I think you got to earlier
but like the losses and games that come
from that from trick and trickable
people but also not tricking like not
basically not bullshitting the like
bullshitter it's just the same thing
right like for you guys you're so close
to this given your age like think about
all the people you try to be friends
with in high school because they were
cool or good looking and then like now
just seven years five years six years
removed from it you're like what the
[ __ ]
you have no interest in those people
it's just that keeps going on past High
School
yes thank you thank you also thank you
Gary for all those very inspiring words
definitely appreciate that makes me feel
better but my question is is definitely
a Hot Topic in my media right now which
is Twitter and so I was part of like the
state the Twitter spaces talk yesterday
and so I felt like got to hear a lot
about like uh elon's like rationale or
basically implementing this Eight dollar
you know verification a month like to
basically weed out all the Bots and like
deception but I'm curious do you think
this is gonna like be a good thing for
Twitter or do you think it's going to be
like the end of it
I don't think it'll be the end of it
until
I mean
look how big Facebook is and Instagram
came along and snap came along and
Tick Tock came along so I think people
think in absolutes the only thing that
will end Twitter
quote unquote AKA
Twitter becomes Myspace is if the
leaders are not capable
my intuition is that Elon is more
capable than the way they've been
running it
and the only other thing that could hurt
it
is market share loss and that would
require somebody to build a better
Twitter
right and so
I don't know if this is going to work
because I'm not in the business of
predicting
I'm in the business of watching all of a
really big point of view on it in 60
days in 150 days
I know that I can tell you that the
problem with people's povs on Twitter is
Elon bleeds a little bit too much into
politics
for people and so they have their hot
takes on their political points of view
not on the rationale of what's Happening
so
you know for me
the global town square
is why I invested in Twitter
right there it's my Twitter stock
certificate I invested in Twitter in
2006 because I was like the World's
Gonna want this
the world needs its place
to talk about the latest
episode of Love Island
the world needs its place to talk about
what happened on Thursday Night Football
the world needs its place to talk about
you know
their favorite couple breaking up it's
it's a human need obviously
the political divide in our country has
been overwhelming and has led to the
anxiety
and people are really good at talking
about all the bad things that social
media has done
without realizing all that social media
is is empty vessels that expose us
and so you know I don't believe one
person on Earth became a racist because
of Facebook
I think Facebook exposed that they were
a racist
and so
I don't know I think social media has
exposed me to be a better person than
people thought because I am a better
person so I think this is a game of
exposing not a game of changing and so
until we realize we have a lot of work
to do on the parenting front and on the
education front
and
humans are audacious
we need we need way more humility
way more humility I love watching all of
you come into Vayner
and thinking you actually know something
about social media because you've been
using it for your teenage years
that has nothing using social media to
hook up
or watch some [ __ ] that you like has
nothing to do with using it to sell [ __ ]
I felt that since joining this company
yeah thank you Gary you got it brother
all right got a couple minutes left
hi Gary thank you for coming to speak
with us today and I appreciate the time
my name is Caitlin I'm on Express as a
media resident and my question kind of
ties in with what you're just talking
about and then back with like toxic work
cultures that have like appear in a lot
of um big companies but not here
thankfully or like at least it like
tries to avoid that and so because as
y'all were just talking about social
media we were I personally am just
coming out of college like we we use
social media in a very different way and
coming into the workforce you kind of
have to realize and we always should
have been monitoring our own media
because it's great that it has like been
super transparent but sometimes I've
heard I've been like scared by what my
parents say like what you put on social
media even college or whatever well then
like you somebody will be like Boo take
it against you and like if like other
work cultures could be so toxic that
they'll somehow find a way that they
lose your job or just take something in
a bad way and I just kind of wonder how
to go about that because I want to
friend my co-worker you wanna you wanna
you want me to give you a real insight
on this yes please
Caleb any company that is going to fire
you because there's a beer pong photo of
you or because you and your friends wore
bikinis on spring break is not a [ __ ]
company you want to work at
true
so there's that you tell Mom and Dad you
don't want to work in those shitholes
anyway
and comma
I've got something even better for all
of you now that you have vaynermedia on
your resume
that completely trumps where the [ __ ]
you went to college and whatever the
[ __ ] you did on social
awesome well I thank you I love that
mindset and I hope to find more more
companies take this mindset with them in
the future they will because as we
continue to crush all of them and get
bigger they're going to have to copy us
exactly thank you Gary all right Crew
Love You This was fun thank you Gary
really appreciate it thanks again
thank you so much thanks Gary love you
guys we love you
[Music]
thank you